ça fait vraiment chaud au coeur de vous
voir ici on rit on pleure c'est en fait
une histoire joyeuse où l'on retrouve
des invités de marque des amis c'est la
fête
on multiplie les signatures
d'autographes
ces lancements de nouveaux livres de
cuisine pour des enfants de 6 à 12 ans
co écrit par les nutritionnistes hélène
laurendeau et catherine des forges
quand on regarde à l'intérieur on
réalise rapidement qu'il est unique ce
livre de cuisine
il n'y a aucune recette c'est
merveilleux a livré cuisine sans recette
les jeunes aujourd'hui c'est pas
vraiment ce qui leur manque des recettes
ils ont des ressources issa comme aller
sur internet
on veut montrer qu est ce que c'est que
cuisiner démystifier ce que c'est
pourquoi il faut lire une recette du
début jusqu'à la fin
question de la différence ans qui mesure
sèche les mesures liquette pourquoi yade
et à sa mesure avec des becs verseurs
comment on tient un couteau pour couper
dans cet immense édifice l'illustratrice
stéphanie aubin loue un minuscule espace
de bureau elle emprunte la table du
voisin pour nous montrer ses dessins en
particulier celui ci c'est le dessin qui
a servi de test bondi fais nous un ou
deux pages et puis si on est satisfait
on va tendre parec toi elle a choisi de
faire un double page avec de l'action un
gâteau qui brûlent surtout un dessin
avec des personnages pour tenter
d'obtenir le contrat d'illustration de
jeux cuisine avec toi c'est un peu aussi
toutes mes inspirations j'aime beaucoup
d'illustrations du milieu du siècle avec
des personnages un peu plus je remettrai
j'aurais que des grosses tailles des
petits yeux c'était le d'importance pour
moi de commencer avec les personnages et
aussi de commencer que cette scène
inquiéter un peu plus amusante d'endives
parce que aussi niveau de l'umoa au
niveau du dessin c'est à dire un peu
déterminé de vivre après ça et
d'esthétique
s'il n'avait pas aimé vous percer
voilà donc au fond c'est un peu ce
travail il faut maintenant illustrer un
livre de 112 pages passer cette étape
est cruciale
c'était un niveau bien produit un
croquis pour chacune des pages du livre
c'est le moment c'est que les autres
vous et d'éditeurs qu'on va s'assurer
qu'on est tous en même temps gardons
donc on va avoir réglé déjà beaucoup de
problèmes au niveau des concepts des
illustrations au niveau de commun même
comique un message après les croquis il
faut produire des dessins au format du
livre qui seront ensuite numérisées
dernière grande étape la colonisation
graphique l'avantagent principal de
faire la colorisation à l'ordinateur
plutôt qu'à la main l'avantagé au niveau
des pour moi mon avantage c'est que je
trouve des classes ont pu vivre un temps
malgré tout mais aussi dans mon style à
moi qui ai un peu plus graphique ça ça
me permet d'avoir des couleurs un peu
plus fortes où c'est un peu plus vive
c'est sa première expérience en
illustrations de livres une expérience
qu'elle voudrait bien renouveler donc
oui c'est sûr j ai tout un univers assez
puis ya tellement de belles opportunités
de bon autant vous savez qui collaborer
donc c'est soit que certains enfants
encore plus si je préfère sa tempe et
s'entretient avec ces moments d'émotion
la soirée de lancement du livre avait un
peu l'air d'une soirée des oscars je
remercie mes parents qui depuis toujours
mon essai dessinée
voilà des remerciements bien mérité
j'avais des problèmes à l'école
j'avais deux heures à l'école j'avais
confiance en moi et depuis que j'ai sur
ma saison depuis que je peux dessiner
mes parents qui ont décidé on devait
faire les deux les parents y ont cru et
aujourd'hui à 30 ans stéphanie aubin est
graphiste illustratrice et professeurs
d'illustration au collège d'un seul